je sais que c'est compliqué pour toi et
que tu passe beaucoup de temps à côtés
et aux côtés de ton papa et on passe on
pensait vraiment voilà là sur le
documentaire on avait clôturé truc ça
passera demain et si tu ne veux pas le
regarder tu as tout à fait le droit et
je comprends tout à fait voilà après
c'est vrai que nous on voulait revoir
voilà des passages aussi de bernard
parce que c'est vrai que bernard il a
traversé plein de choses ces derniers
temps et on l'a même vu j'ai vu que
j'avais un écrivain extrait voilà sur
paris première où il débattait encore
avec ces mots il était extrêmement
combatif et juste voilà on voulait
savoir comment tallinn comment tu te
sens tu es comment commente appréhender
tout ça parce que c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué d'exister en tant qu'artiste
aussi quand on a un nom comme celui de
bernard tapie c'est vrai que voilà est
ce que toi tu arrives à trouver sa
singularité réessaye voilà je suis
auteur compositeur je suis là pour
parler de musique je suis là pour pour
défendre le travail que j'ai essayé de
faire au mieux
c'est ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise non parce qu'en plus je suis comme
tous les enfants de ou les proches de
quelqu'un qui a un cancer quoi français
je suis ton calme et a pas il ya plein
de façons cette maladie est que ce soit
le malade ou les proches tout le monde
souffre et sayyaf un essai c'est tout
promet le premier titre que tu as dans
ton album s'appelle le phénix exactement
c'est un titre que tu écris pour ton
papa ouais tu peux nous raconter
ça faisait très longtemps que je l'avais
écrit et puis j'ai beaucoup hésité
entre autres pour ce genre de raison de
le sortir parce que je me suis dit
est-ce que c'est pas à me tirer une
balle dans le pied de faire leurs titres
sur lui parce que j'essaye au fur et à
mesure de jessey du mieux que je peux
donc faire un prénom
et du coup je me suis dit est-ce que
c'est pas me tirer une balle dans le
pied parce qu'on va me reparler de lui
encore mais quand quelqu'un est malade
du cancer en général on pense plus avec
son cerveau ont pensé qu soccer et
j'avais peur de regretter de si je le
faisais pas donc voilà je l' ai vraiment
fait parce que leur santé le besoin
alors on va on va regarder le clip qui
s'appelle le phoenix ouais bon bah c'est
tout est dans le titre oui comment il a
écouté ton papa il l'a écoutée l'aï là
il la regardait seul il n'a pas voulu
que ce soit avec lui je pense que très
pudique aussi là dessus et donc je pense
qu'il avait besoin de procès c'est tout
seul je sais qu'il aime beaucoup ce que
tu fais ben oui mais je peux quand même
pas pas avec ses enfants il est à fond
pour gaza car ils écoutent tout ce que
tu fais il est il y à fond derrière top
ce qu'ils aiment ce que tu fais je pense
qu'il trouve vraiment que tu a un énorme
talent moi il m'a parlé de toi plein de
fois il m'a dit vraiment que à chaque
fois que j'avais au téléphone couteau
qui très fier de mes frères et soeurs
aussi moi je sais et voilà et on va
regarder alors le phénix ces titres que
tu écris pour ton papa écoutez bien bien
sûr les paroles c'est le premier titre
de ton album regarde
[Musique]
on me le fait ni
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sophie tapie donc c'est le premier titre
de ton album le phénix renaît de ses
cendres c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu
bernard tapie mais c'est vrai que c'est
ici on a l'impression que toute sa vie
c'est un battoir cinq ans maintenant
tout voilà ce qui attend
et c'est voilà c'est ce que tu dis dans
le dans le titre puis c'était aussi une
manière de de parler un peu de cette
maladie parce que voilà je sais que les
thèmes abordés sur mon album sont pas
tous super joyeux sait mais on parle de
la vieillesse on peut parler des
chagrins d'amour on peut parler de de
l'ecologie voilà ce sont ce sont des
combats qui me sont chers mais le phénix
est aussi exactement ce qui se passe
quand on est atteint d'un cancer c'est
que c'est très cyclique il ya des jours
ça va bien il ya des jours où ça va
moins bien puis il ya cette espèce de
même quand on est en rémission on a
toujours été de l'épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête en se disant est ce
que je vais pas rechuter est ce que est
ce que je vais m'en sortir donc c'était
c'est aussi vraiment ça le l'espèce des
normes combat cycliques ya dans cette
danse est malade y est on est on en
n'est jamais vraiment guéri de ce
traumatisme heures c'est ce que tu
racontes comme dans le titre aujourd'hui
tu es tu le vois tous les jours tu
restes avec lui tous les jours oui mais
comme comme comme mes frères et soeurs
comme beaucoup de gens passent le voir
et ça lui fait ça lui fait très très
plaisir
voilà c'était avec huit ans il y
[Musique]
en a pas du tout par l'italie n'a pas
dit ce qu'il avait pensé de dollars ait
besoin de se parler ouais parler avec
les yeux je sais qu'il est il a aimé oui
je suis persuadé qu'il a aimée de tout
façon très honnêtement je pense que même
si j'avais fait un truc pourri et ouais
[Rires]
c'est un papa koala bah ouais et c'est
ça oui peut dire d'un truc perso vous
êtes allé en angleterre en 2005 en 2006
tout comme ça et moi je vais interviewer
un ou deux jours avant et il était
incapable de parler d'autre chose que de
samedi portaient un pitre en compte elle
va en angleterre où les anglais la voit
jouer il était fasciné par ça elle vos
capacités de comédienne donc la chanson
we et la comédie aussi oui bernard
jugent ils vous avez une tête de bernard
l'album est magnifique parce que très
personnel il ya le phénix il ya mon
corps à réparer qui est une très belle
chanson et dans dans le phoenix on sent
tout l'amour de la famille et moi ce que
je voulais vous dire ce soir c'est que
honnêtement ne soyez pas mal à l'aise on
aimait mots auront beaucoup moins
d'impact que ceux de cyril mais je vais
vous le dire avec tout mon coeur on est
tous là tels que nous sommes tous les
gens là tous ceux qui nous regardent
avec vous aux côtés de la famille aux
côtés du combat de votre père qu'on
adore et on vous adore pour cet amour de
la famille unie dans son combat et on
espère tous qu'il va gagner parce que
c'est un beau combat et donc on est
vraiment avec vous et on vous aime
beaucoup
de chance enfin moi je le vois
quand canton j'ai vu des gens en chimio
et souvent les gens sont seuls parce que
cette maladie fait peur
les gens ont peur comme si les impairs
que ce soit contagieux un peu
les gens qui sont branchés en chimio ils
sont là sur leur ipad sur leurs mots
croisés sur la photo ils sont ils sont
ils sont très seuls c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui effraie les gens
cancer et je sais qu'on a énormément de
chance et parfois c'est presque malaison
pour nous parce que l'on dit qu'on a
beaucoup plus de chances que certains
donc c'était aussi un peu ma manière de
le rendre aux autres aussi et puis il
faut que tu fasses ta cas il faut que tu
chantes tu dis ouais c'est parce que
tapie on va me dire ces tapis mais on te
dira toujours contre amènera toujours at
on pas parce que ton papa je vais te
dire il appartient à tout le monde ton
papa il appartient aux gens alors il
décrivant il ya eu ces trucs mais il est
parti de rien j'ai vu chanter moi une
première fois à tf1 après il après
l'oeil son bateau je les ai vus faire
plein de trucs j'ai vu faire du cinéma
j'ai vu faire du théâtre j'ai vu faire
du rap avec doc gynéco j'ai vu acheté
adidas je les ai vus donner la ligue des
champions l'olympique de marseille
d'abord qu'on l'appelle comment à
marseille tout le peuple marseillais
l'abbé commenges le boss s'est passé par
ayant donc tu pourra jamais enlever une
histoire d'honneur mais bien sûr il va
passer en loucedé qu'on en parle
maintenant si bien dire voilà écoutez
tout il a donné énormément de bonheur
aux gens bernard tapie l'a donné
énormément de bonheur à des gens qui en
avaient besoin et je sens c'est le boss
mois bernard tapie pour